on this episode we talk about e-commerce
Twitter search and self-awareness
[Music]
[Music]
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 108 of the askgaryvee
show hey guys you can go back to your
you know well Katie get prepared
cuz anything is possible any time
alright India let's get into why don't
you show India when I say this I think
it's or do you think it's more
interesting okay let's get into the show
it's kind of weird to have you on the
right side of it I'm like I feel this
confabulated yeah
are you lefty makes so much sense all
three of you
Yuvraj asks what is the one thing that
is still missing according to you in the
e-commerce space
this time it's answered Yuvraj so I
think the one thing missing in EECOM
right now there's a couple things that
are not are missing but I'm very curious
and completely obsessed with who's gonna
be the first EECOM player that is mobile
only
or like disproportionally mobile first ,
then I mean I almost want their desktop
EECOM site to almost be broken like in
the way that people were broken on
mobile 2 or 3 years ago I think there's
a play and a way to destruct Amazon or
other players and niche spaces where you
are so natively mobile as all the
behavior goes this way maybe even mobile
II this way that the thing that's
missing is in the way that Twitter and
Instagram became mobile for social
networks and really had a big win in
that way a snapchat I do think there's
an evolution of EECOM players that are
mobile first in their attack and so I'm
excited about that I think there's going
to be a player that emerges the next
half-decade then is very mobile centric
a mobile only maybe even which I think
would be a big stance and an interesting
stance and one that you know would
almost be a marketing ploy that doesn't
work on desktop if you really want to
bet on three four five six seven years
out which I believe econ behavior on
mobile devices will be
extraordinary so thing that's missing is
the opportunity at hand for that mobile
execution in Econ ryan asked what
environment is best for you to have
successful business meetings in
conference room restaurant in flight Rd
for me I'm looking to do these meetings
anywhere possible at all times I will
sell and bizdev and make the action
happen on a flight on a toilet in the in
the office outside at a ballgame walking
the halls in the bathroom I don't give a
crap
I said that's something twice think
about that that is like that is where my
mindset is on this which is I will go
anywhere inappropriate I would go I
would go anywhere you want to meet you
know you want to meet at a funeral
parlor to close a deal I'm interested
just give me the directions I'll be
there in a minute
so I think to me it doesn't matter where
it is or how it goes down I'm
comfortable in all environments and
business settings
you know conference rooms you know are
fine I don't have a problem with that
either I don't want to be cool and do it
anywhere like I'm just I'm really up for
whatever when it comes to closing a
business deal or doing some biz dev and
so not some cool place like a coffee
shop not some sterile old-school place
like a conference room literally
everything in between just anywhere
no meeting at the grave it's going down
banning elevator wants to know how do I
use Twitter search for something as
unique as elevators that's a good
question I love talking about Twitter
search something we haven't talked about
in a long time I think Twitter searches
the most interesting functionality in
Twitter maybe besides video replies
which I've been knocking out of the park
I think that that's a tough one you know
first of all is it elevator repairs are
they selling elevators like what are
what are they doing you know to me you
know Twitter search is amazing but
there's clearly certain very narrow
niche things that may not over-index
in that environment you know if you're I
see India's doing some work to try to
figure this out if you're doing elevator
repair or selling elevators you know
Twitter's not gonna be the most fertile
grounds of people being like you know I
don't I don't feel like I'm building a
building right now as a developer in
2015 yeah then make them enough give it
right you know I don't think these
developers in today's day and age maybe
in 20 years something like Twitter but I
don't think a developer's like hey
building a building won't rain what to
do with the elevator
you know I think you're better off going
into the content game maybe creating an
infographic of like seven unknown facts
of elevator upkeep and then making that
a SlideShare and a Pinterest pin and
then directing it into linked in and
running ads against the people that make
those decisions at you know at developer
firms so I don't think Twitter searches
is probably worth your while
I think the other thing you could do if
you decide to make a very heavy consumer
facing brand I think the one white space
for b2b people is to make some make
really intriguing videos that aren't
boring that could create general
awareness right I think general
awareness when you think about Intel
it's a chip right like but there's
general awareness around and you start
looking for it there may be a play where
you make videos that are whether they're
funny whether they're intrigued
thought-provoking emotional videos for
b2b companies that create mass awareness
that then allude to we're sitting in a
room as developers and saying you know
we're building out the scope and of
course we're looking at our peace and
our advise and looking at like the cost
but you know having our brand top of
mind is good to even get into that play
and that's branding versus sales Twitter
search isn't is a non recommended play
in June third as a June third on June
3rd 26 to 2015 for elevator many
factures and service providers not am
NOT a recommendation no no no Jason
wants to know who do you ask when you
have life for business questions Jason
this is my strength and my weakness and
so I want to set that up immediately I
ask absolutely nobody it is insane that
III think about this all the time and I
clearly and you know what it's funny
subconscious I said to my strength in my
weakness I guess maybe that answers my
5149 question of is it a strength or a
weakness I do think about it a lot I do
I do wonder why I'm not really mentored
out even with the most amazing dad who
was in the business you know I you know
I was mentored you know and maybe this
is just the way I roll maybe I'm being
mentored by example you know I think my
parents my parents you know 20 I'm gonna
be a different parent I think and like
sit down my kids and do my spiel I mean
I love doing this imagine me as a dad
I'm like kid when the wind blows the
blow you know like you know dude [ __ ]
like that you know like I never really
went that route I watched my parents and
maybe I watched other people and I you
know Steve Ross who's my LP and and an
investor partner now one of most
successful businessmen of the last 100
years in the u.s. you know I full access
to him at a scary level and I don't hit
him up for like what do you think and
this is a guy who's owns a football team
you know five billion dollar man and I
never sit down and ask him I'm like let
me tell you like I just it's it's in me
it says it's again it's either a
strength or a weakness but the true
answer the question is absolutely nobody
I I'm a big believer that people should
see
psychiatrist and invent and like do that
I don't do that even though I believe in
a tremendously I don't think I'm a
hypocrite because the truth is it's
stunning and by the way if I ever go
through a path if I had if I ever went
through a sustained 36 hour period of
being really upset I would do it in a
heartbeat I would change my behavior but
I am so scared and so blessed and so
thankful and so grateful for the
perspective that I have as a human being
which is you just can't wrap your head
my friends vaynernation you just cannot
wrap your head around the excitement
that I would have in my body if all the
things on paper that seemed like my
successes would disappear tomorrow
obviously I want to take care of my
family
and put a roof over their head and those
kind of things but you do not understand
my lack of taste for caviar like I just
don't give a [ __ ] like I love the game
you know I love the Jets in the mix
because they don't win you understand
and so for me the fear of failure is not
a fear at all so in fact I would argue
that I have more fear for success than I
have fear for failure and so because of
that I don't know it puts me in a very
happy place
I I don't look for advice because the
truth is I don't want to screw anything
up like I don't go and speak to somebody
to that because I don't want to screw
anything up like I feel like the
chemicals are aligned right now I'm very
happy I'm super duper duper happy cool
Ryan what can I make Q's outfit tonight
it's show the nation something good with
that
he's got that mustard going and that
collars legit
yeah the mustard alright got that
mustard brought the mustard all right
let's go Ryan asked how can you claim a
family first but work 19 hours a day how
can it be a good dad - hubby and rarely
be home yeah so this is a this a great
question and I like the zing of the
hashtag at the end what's the name
Ryan let me explain something to you
partner and everybody else who asks me
about this question this is a very legit
question and so I'm not angry or looking
to zing back because you're right this
has a lot to do with decisions that my
wife and I have made about the way I
story tell my life versus the way I
story tell my private life you know I
look at things in net game form right
for example but let's just I just as my
friend this is actually very convenient
didn't even think about this because I
didn't really know the questions today
I just I just I just zoom in indie rock
let's just zoom in where I was this
morning cuz I worked out at six right
you tell me when and you may not be able
to pull it off you think you'd be able
to pull it off
not even close I can yeah yep good so
look look at this ha ha ha I went to the
kindergarten play today right I went to
the kindergarten plays my friend was
there a half an hour early to be first
in line at the kindergarten play this
morning and you know look look look at
this stuff that I never shared this one
even have to blur out do you rock cuz
this is the point of the answer but here
we go let's just see the last couple of
videos that were taken look look at
these look at these videos look at these
videos of you know kids singing you know
kids singing yeah kids my friends here's
what this one comes down to and I have
enormous amounts of empathy and
self-awareness to why this question is
asked all the time and when I talk about
19-hour neza when i'm d-roc and i and
some on put out a day in a life video
and it shows all this and nobody wants
to envy it I'm playing in extremes first
and foremost when there are important
events like this you know the kind of
things that my dad never came to because
he set the foundation to her I'm there
I'm at the play I'm at the recital I'm
at this I'm there on weekends I'm all in
all in my friends all in on weekends
right I'm not playing for hours of golf
like a lot of you I'm not doing a lot of
other things that a lot of people are
doing I'm all in on the kids right then
I'm taking oh I don't know seven seven
weeks of vacation which is probably in
the ballpark of four or five weeks more
than you write more than you which is
high quality time all
every second and so yes maybe I'm
playing Monday through Friday you know
40 weeks a year at an intensity that's
different but I have found my cadence my
rhythm my mic my balance with my spouse
and my children predicated on playing it
that way and I'm finding a lot of
quality time with them in these extremes
and so you know I think I ever judge or
ask or tell anybody how to raise their
family to do their thing the other thing
I've decided is unlike a lot of my
contemporaries and a lot of social media
experts who I don't think exploit their
kids on social networks but I would say
are intriguing about being so obsessed
with getting likes and hearts that they
know when they use their cute kids they
get more it's kind of I've been in many
conversations sitting right here at
conferences I'm right here but I'm
listening always you know because that's
how I roll and I'm doing my thing and
I've heard many people talk about
strategies around how oh put your kids
and stuff you'll get more likes I'm like
really
so you know I've chosen my wife is
chosen we have chosen to you know as you
guys know there are very few pictures or
any kind of public pictures of my wife
or my kids it's just what's comfortable
to us so very self-aware about the
rationale to why people may question my
ability to be a good dad or do my thing
the other part of this answer is
missions and or three and six this is
the system and they were two and five
five seconds ago and into the death you
know as things evolve as they're in
softball and soccer and football and
this and that you know there's you know
I'll adjust and my schedules will change
and you know big thing in 2016 are
beginning a lot of thought to is coming
home every day at 5:00 p.m. for 30 40
minutes to eat or bathing so I'll adjust
and I'll try and I'll hustle and I'll
work and I'll continue to always
struggle with work-life balance given my
happiness and my ambition my selfishness
around work however there are a lot more
things going on here than just the
things you're making assumptions on
rightfully so given the content that
putting out but that's why even that
video we talked about and ended with and
Big Ups to Alex on our team to push this
which really made that video hole which
was that's me do you and so I feel super
cozy about the time allocation I would
also argue my friend about quality
because plenty people will work nine to
five come home drink a beer watch TV
play video games and spend oh I don't
know six seconds yelling at their kids
to do homework and so there's quantity
which you know I like to think I may be
playing a good game on on extremities
and then there's also quality like you
know actually having a relationship like
actually having a conversation actually
spending quality time actually looking
them in the eye actually actually
actually so that's my answer to that
question friends you want to ask do you
believe in aliens I do believe in aliens
I'm not sure if I do let's talk about
this for a second this is more gray in
my opinion dirac it's not official
question do you believe in aliens I
wonder [ __ ] you know what I'm not even
gonna listen to your answer but do you
believe in aliens straight-up like on
the record forever yes okay
used to fun no do you rock I'm sure I'm
on the end
d-roc you have to answer question life
on the line yes or no simple
simple it's not really complicated quote
me to I I think that I think space goes
way further than our solar system what
I'm curious about and way more intrigued
by is I actually think there's another
Gary Vaynerchuk in a different world
yeah really like yeah I mean I'm so
curious of Gary in a different galaxy is
crushing it
where's a question today do you believe
in aliens you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
thanks for watching on youtube I know
I've been pushing the Facebook videos
but the YouTube pre means a ton to me
appreciate you and the other thing and
I've been watching I know the NSA thing
is weird a lot of you haven't subscribed
yet do it